[Musique]
bah c'est sûr qu'il fait partie de notre
équipe
un élément incontournable de notre
équipe a vu comme on disait les coaches
la fédération jean pierre jean pierre
c'est jean pierre riou pelle depuis
quinze ans il affûte les lames des plus
grands patineurs artistiques de la
planète
aujourd'hui on retrouve parmi ses
clients les champions du monde le couple
français gabriela papadakis et guillaume
cizeron je donne mes patins et il me les
amène le matin avant l'entraînement
si j'avais lu arrivé un truc de
téléphone c'est d'être constant à chaque
fois c'est vraiment sur l'importance le
met où sont guéris sur la glace parce
que il parle de montréal your touch plus
est les personnes qui touchent à leurs
patins le bon usage des exemples sont
capables de tout à fait un 30 hommes
avant les compétitions me viennent
exemple en début de semaine puis vont
ramener la veille avant de partir on
patine et peut-être un accord avec qui
partent en compétition les champions
olympiques les canadiens tessa virtue et
scott moir yeux qui viennent de prendre
leur retraite ont longtemps fait
confiance à jean pierre riou pelle
tellement que même à l'autre bout du
monde les 10 heures devait répondre aux
urgences
trois jours de suite on ne trouvait pas
pourquoi que l'on appelle son aile sur
le patin qui à chaque fois ils partent à
chaque pratique qui m emmener j'ai comme
allumer
j'ai dit et ça envoie une photo de ton
protège l'âme puis il y avait plein de
petites roches dans son protège dents
faut qu on ait pris les protège amont
les amis ou poubelle puis prés salés
jamais eu de problèmes avec ses patins
le plus grand stress de jean-pierre
n'est pas d'avoir des doutes sur son
travail
non son stress c'est de regarder glisser
ses patins lors des grandes compétitions
stress et à chaque fois je regarde à la
télé là je tombe puis à d'assez par les
vacances croisera jean pierre riou paix
les 850 l'âme par semaine sans
distinction qu'on soit champion du monde
ou champion en devenir comme le couple
canadien caroline sous 6 et sean faris
ses adversaires sur glace mais dans la
vie tous les jours sont toujours ainsi
des bons amis sont toujours ensemble
puisque ce n'est pas le patin je vois le
canada l'espagne la grande-bretagne la
chine le japon je veux tout les joueurs
différents pays chacun leur intention
ils ont tout jeté de l'amitié différente
avec chacun puis tout le monde mérite de
la même chose ici robert frosi
radio-canada verdun